well so it is fabulous to have you here
with us it's nice time a real
quarterback is on the set he knows this
I wax poetically about you all the time
who we saying the Seahawks are making
the playoffs this year when you workout
it no doubt you recall on the team where
the season even began he was talking
about he was he was all over you guys I
got to give him credit for that but no
you are the man first of all I dig this
little emblem thing you like you like
I'm going to give you I'll sport it give
me the I'll give you my hat your asset
giving you I'm going to give you the
emblem okay then I hit him on the three
logo I'm to give you the glasses to come
on I mean I'll wear it yeah I don't care
a little boy will I promise you that
these afterwards I'll take them right
now that's actually pretty sick I've
been wearing those all day there's a
news that Bose frames you know Ciara nah
we listen to music all the time
obviously and so I'm constantly on phone
calls and these things these things are
amazing that's like majoring stuff so
you guys really did have a year that a
lot of people didn't expect and I
remember talking to you after the Lions
game yeah then it felt like 2012 all
over again that no one believed and you
were building something so if that was
2012 is 2019 gonna be 2013 well
precedent is anything then hopefully
it'll be a good time for us next year
but you know I think that the thing that
we did really well was we came back in
this offseason you know this past one we
just had came back into OTAs it was all
a fresh new start and the leaders like
myself Bobby Doug balban's of the world
Tyler Lockett Duane Browns
Justin Brits you know we came in and we
we kind of revamp that we kind of
revamped the meeting room we kind of
revamped the feel with how we practice
the locker room just hey this is this is
a new year or new time all right it's a
fresh us and so let's let's let's shock
the world everybody say I'm gonna be two
in 14 or they're rebuilding is good
there's no time for that as time is now
and I think we were able to do that and
to be quite quite frank with you
we're a little disappointing we're not
here right now yeah we really feel like
we could have been here and we had
moments not just moments we a lot of
moments that really where we showed
where we could really go take this Ryan
I go back to the Rams game at home when
we played the Rams there on the feet at
the time we had the ball in a 31 garland
go
yes he's in a row unfortunately yeah I
know and if we can fine-tune those
little details right those are the
things that's gonna take the team over
the top yeah I think that you know
that's your first round bye as the
jingle growth happens right and and we
understand that and that's where we were
able to transition they're getting a
bunch of wins middle to latest season we
were able to knock those things out of
the way
does it bug you to see the Rams here
because you guys gave them all they can
handle twice why you want it scored
against them twice do you see that and
think I wish it was somebody else
well you wasn't obviously you wish it
was you we always but you obviously
realize that you know that should have
been that could have should have been us
you know if we had done things right I
feel like just throughout the process
and I don't mean that in a negative way
I look at a most positive way that hey
we're we're on our way and you know
obviously next you everybody's has to
stay healthy and all those little
details of that but hey we got we got we
got the right guys in the room and
that's all we need you know and so we
just got to continue to build continue
to get better we had a great season this
year I thought well we continue to
progress I'm excited about our young
corners you know flowers playing corner
I feel I think about a Chris Carson and
his running running ability I think
about I'll receive tyler lockett having
10 touchdowns this to your shopping
honey looks like you know there's a lot
of guys and and realities we didn't even
even throw the ball that much but we can
scored a lot of touchdowns throwing the
ball in right and how much more can we
do that's what I look forward to can we
get three percent better and that's how
I look at it well I mean that's why
you're Russell Wilson and you're one of
the three four best quarterbacks in
football every year I'm amazed at what
you do I really am I mean your talent is
off the charts and you have broken molds
in the NFL I mean right now the new
thing is Kyle or Murray is he too short
to play I mean just what's your mindset
when you hear that type of talk about
you know the quarterback position well I
think guys helped break the mold for me
beforehand you know I think guys like
Steve Young sure guys like Michael Vick
here in l Hanna yeah he played I think
guys I think guys like Drew Brees
obviously you know he's one of my
favorite favorite players and favorite
people that know now watching those guys
play and then I was fortunate to come in
and play right away and be very very
successful right away and been blessed
to go to two Super Bowls win won my
second year you know and so I think it
it really helped crack the door open for
a lot of other guy
like caller Murray guys Baker Mayfield
is playing great yeah I know right so
you made him a number one pick well I'm
not you know I don't know about that I
think he's for hard work well I know I
know but you know what I'm saying if I
was able to go again maybe they'd pick
me a little bit early yeah I think so
any fifth yeah but you know I think that
at the end of the day you know if you
could play ball you can play ball it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter your
circumstances and I think there's a lot
of guys that can play a lot of great
football yeah what was your reaction the
first time you saw what Patrick mahomes
can do man he's special I was just with
them I was just with him in the Pro Bowl
have a lot of you know great time when
we batted in our game you know back and
forth which we were fortunate to win but
he was unbelievable that night you know
he's up you know he's a great player he
can make every throw he's got a great
demeanor he's calm he's poised right kid
he's really special yeah when you see
what a guy like that can do does that
even at this point in your career you've
been around seven seasons now does this
inspire you to try to find things he
does that maybe you can incorporate you
even though up to up to and including a
loan look pass yeah you know I think you
build all those things that you continue
to grow and you know you know I think he
gets a lot of that we were talking about
you the other day a lot of us from
baseball you know you feel ground balls
you know as the guys hitting VP you
start throwing at the first base so you
know I think a lot of that is his he's
very charismatic on the field you know I
mean he can make some special things
happen and yeah there's there's only a
handful of guys that can make special
plays like that out of nowhere and he's
one of those guys to Super Bowl
appearances one-on-one which one do you
think about more I mean I think about
the one I won more than do you yeah I
know sometimes as a competitor though
you think about that one that got away
where you know that was a horrible
calling for that last play I don't got
to say it I just gotta say right there
it didn't work sure but I think I think
at the end of the day you know you
throughout your career you're gonna
you're gonna have great times we're
gonna have tough moments too that helped
build you up for the next great time
yeah and I think that's how I look at it
you know we've had a lot of amazing
moments when a lot of football games
right and one lot of football games and
so how many more can we win how many
more can we do so that's what I look
forward to every day when I wake up
playing the the Patriots just what's the
first thing that you think about and
your experience I think you've played
them three times of course once in the
Superbowl two regular season what's the
first thing that jumps to your mind when
you think about them execution yeah
I think that you know as the opposing
team you had to execute great right um
you know you got to do what you you know
got to do the little things right I
think ultimately too as well as you know
we got to be clutching in tight moments
in third downs you got to be able to
make your plays you know I think the two
games that we were able to beat them
they played in three times that you said
the two times you're able to beat then
we were really clutch on third downs
really clutch in the fourth quarter I
remember my first game my rookie year
everyone rookie year playing time who
knows yeah be able to make some plays I
think we're down like 14 or something
attainable pose for a I think a lot of
that is is being clutched in the moments
but also you got to find ways to try to
slow down Tom as much as possible easy
he's as good as it gets you know and
greatest of all time you know arguably
and obviously and so I think that when
you think about that you know I think
the biggest thing that the Rams can try
to do is find James White because he's
my old teammate yeah he is tough to
cover he's dumped to defend he's tough
to tackle right he could be the
difference maker in this game right you
mentioned baseball when we were talking
about Patrick mahomes he mentioned Kyler
Murray and Murray office is gonna have
to make this choice between baseball and
football what advice would you give him
if he were to ask you about which way he
should go well that's a great question I
think first of all for me I could go
back to my experience the first thing I
did was pray about it you know that's
the first thing I think the second thing
is write down all the pros and cons yeah
you know there's gonna be a lot more
pros than cons in this situation you
know funny thing is is when you're
blessed to be able to play both
potentially in the major leagues in NFL
it almost feels like a Kirsten away can
your Charlie what do I do
well I think the good thing about this
situation is is that no matter what he
chooses it's gonna be a great thing he's
a great player he's a great person you
know I think ultimately do what you love
most you know the thing for me I love
the game being the ball being in my
hands when the game's on the line four
minutes to go two minutes to go one
minute to go
you know you know I want to strike fear
in a defense and that's what I love more
than anything else is everybody either
rooting for you rooting against you and
so that was the cool thing I loved the
Bose is paying the bills yeah yeah so
obviously Bose is a the NFL sponsor you
know and everything else with the
National Football League the QC 35
headphones to to headphones and then
also I got these these frames which I
told you guys about earlier
been rocking the air-cool Madden rocking
these all day you know I'm doing
conference calls I'm doing listen to me
that's amazing oh so I'm having fun with
these things but this is pretty sick and
so uh so yeah it's been exciting you
know it's been exciting just to be able
to work with Bose as obvious is a
pleasure to be here with the NFL and
everything we have time for a fishbowl
beachball random question random
questions all right I'm gonna pick this
one right here
got you okay whoa what's a good one man
if you could win any Olympic medal okay
if you could win any Olympic medals
summer or winter what would it be oh
well first of all would be gold and
second of all I would love to bowl
saying you're my god I would love to be
the Satan ball in a race if I could do
it but you know I don't he was gonna add
he's not gonna beat you throw the
football further than him right right
they should have a throwing contest you
know football should be an Olympic event
I've been saying it for years Anna
listen to me listen what ball is growing
you know I've been fortunate to go to
China lately been fortunate to go to
Europe and in London and all that kind
of stuff and we're going to Brazil hurts
me and CR soon too as well we'd do a lot
stuff with NFL right it's growing it's
amazing just from year one to year two
what had the growth of football in China
was there's just a drastically different
so it's exciting times
well Russell it's exciting to talk to
you is always we wish you all the best
great to see congratulations on 2018 /
2012 good luck in 29000 I like the way
you're thinking like
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports